[Musique]
une chance contre nous aucune nation n'est plus
préparée ou plus résiliente que les
États-Unis nous avons la meilleure économie
les soins de santé les plus avancés et les
médecins scientifiques et
chercheurs les plus talentueux du monde
le virus n'aura aucune chance contre
nous  aucune nation n'est plus préparée ou plus
résiliente que les États-Unis, nous avons
la meilleure économie, les
soins de santé les plus avancés et les
médecins, scientifiques et chercheurs les plus
talentueux du monde.
Pâques est un jour très spécial
pour de nombreuses raisons.  beaucoup de nos
amis c'est un jour très spécial et
quelle belle chronologie ce serait
Pâques est notre chronologie quelle belle
chronologie ce serait
quelqu'un a perdu quelqu'un un parent ou une
femme ou un mari ou vous savez des
frères sœurs ils seraient perdus  quelqu'un que
tu ne pourras jamais rattraper en
disant pourquoi tu vas avoir une excellente
année l'année prochaine économiquement et donc tu
ne pourras jamais faire ça mais je dirai que
d'un point de vue économique  int Je pense que l'
année prochaine va être une très grosse année cette
énorme demande nous avons subi la
pire attaque que nous ayons jamais eue contre notre
pays c'est vraiment la pire attaque que
nous ayons jamais eue c'est pire que Pearl
Harbor c'est pire que  le World
Trade Center il n'y a jamais eu d'
attaque comme celle-ci
et puis je vois le désinfectant ou il l'
assomme en une minute
une minute et y a-t-il un moyen de faire
quelque chose comme ça par injection à l'intérieur
ou presque un nettoyage parce que vous voyez qu'il
pénètre  les poumons et cela fait un
nombre énorme, il serait donc
intéressant de vérifier cela pour que vous
deviez faire appel à des médecins
pourquoi continuez-vous d'appeler cela le
virus chinois il y a des rapports de dizaines d'
incidents de partialité contre les
Américains d'origine chinoise  dans ce pays le vôtre un
secrétaire un tsar dit qu'il n'utilise pas
ce terme parce que l'ethnicité ne
cause pas le virus pourquoi continuez-vous à l'
utiliser vient en profiter ce n'est pas du tout raciste
non pas du tout ça vient de Chine
c'est pourquoi  vient de Chine je veux être
précis je suis un peu en colère contre la Chine
je vais être honnête avec vous car
autant j'aime le président Xi et autant je
respecte le pays et j'admire le
pays pour lequel j'ai une grande admiration  le
pays ce qu'ils ont fait en
peu de temps, bien sûr, nos présidents
nos présidents précédents ont permis que
cela se produise, vous devriez leur dire merci
beaucoup à tous, mais ils auraient dû
nous en parler et ils l'ont
mal appelé ils l'appellent  tort, ils ont vraiment
raté l'appel, ils auraient pu l'
appeler des mois plus tôt, ils l'auraient
su et ils auraient dû le savoir et
ils le savaient probablement, nous allons donc
examiner cela très attentivement et
nous allons suspendre l'argent dépensé pour
le w-h-o nous allons mettre une
emprise très puissante dessus et nous allons voir que
c'est une bonne chose si cela fonctionne, mais quand
ils appellent chaque coup mal, ce n'est pas
bon ma question est avez-vous vu
quelque chose à ce stade qui vous donne un
haut degré de confiance e  à l'
Institut de biologie de Wuhan était l'origine de
ce virus oui oui et je pense que l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé devrait avoir
honte d'elle-même
parce qu'elle est comme l'
agence de relations publiques pour la Chine
je n'en porte pas moi-même c'est une
recommandation qu'ils  le recommande je me
sens bien je ne veux tout simplement pas
faire je ne sais pas d'une manière ou d'une autre assis dans
le bureau ovale derrière ce beau
bureau résolu le grand bureau résolu
je pense porter un masque facial alors que je salue les
présidents les premiers ministres les dictateurs les
rois  reines je ne sais pas d'une manière ou d'une autre
je ne le vois pas par moi-même